[Music]
Hi Sam thank you so much for joining me
today welcome back to San Luis how does
it feel to be back
um I mean it feels amazing to play in a
new tournament that I've never played in
St Louis it's the fair my favorite City
to play and be in and you mentioned this
is the first time you're playing in one
of these events at the club chess 9lx
what did you do to prepare for the
tournament I love playing chess 960 for
fun in general it just shows the
creativity of a player and usually I
just play a lot of games online like
Blitz rapid games 960. I try to
understand how the engine thinks in 960
because it's totally different from
regular regular chess position so it's
going to be very interesting and very
fun and for this specific event the
you're going to get the position 15
minutes before you actually have to play
it how do you feel about that how
important are those 15 minutes to get
you ready for the game uh obviously
chess has been around for a for so many
for centuries and the initial position
has been analyzed and analyzed and
understand we can still find new things
so 15 minutes is really absolutely
nothing for us especially without a
computer but I think that we can maybe
grasp some ideas and try to get at least
some ideas in the position
some of the players mentioned that in
the past they kind of talked to some of
the their competitors obviously not the
one they were playing against you think
you might be doing that as well to kind
of create a team with someone and just
prepare a little bit or you're gonna try
to do it on your own I mean I don't
think it would hurt to analyze with
somebody because maybe they see
something that you don't and
maybe you can even come up with a little
opening three into 10 minutes you have
what do you think is the most important
thing in chess 960 is it pattern
recognition visualization is it the pawn
structure
I honestly think it's intuition if you
have good tactical sense in 960 you will
have a good time in my opinion because a
lot of positions aren't symmetrical and
it could be really Pawn structures that
you've never seen before in our
classical normal starting position so if
you have good tactical awareness and in
general creativity I think that'll help
you a lot in 960.
okay and is there a specific exercise
that you found to be effective to
improve your visualization skills
overall for chess and then maybe you
could use those for this event too
uh I think it's just solving and solving
and solving I mean there's no secret
sauce to calculating better and
visualizing
um
ocean that I wanted to ask you is
um whether this variant is your favorite
variants I know you've mentioned you
play it online do you like other kind of
variants as well or is this would you
say it's your favorite this is my
favorite variant because it's it's still
chess uh there are other variants that
are very fun as well but the concepts of
the game are completely different and I
mean 960 definitely has a future in
chess because if the first position
dries out completely we can definitely
and probably should move to that 60.
participant are you looking forward to
the most to play against in this event
uh I mean Hikaru is so creative and
strong that it's always exciting games
I've played some games in 960 with them
and would definitely
enjoy playing with him nice
nice in this event thank you
[Music]